après la présentation des 112
proposition du btp les candidats
présents avaient à chaque fois un temps
pour répondre et faire leurs
propositions aux professionnels du
bâtiment devant un public attentif
ils ont les uns après les autres exposer
leurs idées et fait part de leur soutien
un secteur important de l'économie
locale le bâtiment représente en effet
cinquante mille entreprises mais aussi
15 mille pme et 35 mille artisans dans
leur quotidien les artisans et chefs
d'entreprises du bâtiment souhaitent
avant tout qu'on leur simplifie la vie
et il semble avoir été entendu par les
candidats principale demande le besoin
de simplification administrative
réponses des candidats
aujourd'hui pour réaliser un chantier
toutes les autorisations en amont et
toutes les contraintes pour réaliser
sont telles que démobilise je dirais les
entreprises
la concertation et la simplification
pour les entreprises du bâtiment me
paraît être un point très important déjà
alors c'est pas les seuls parce qu'il ya
en même temps tout ce qui concerne la
formation est aussi l'apprentissage
s'est créé un guichet unique pour des
formalités administratives pour toutes
les tpe pme qui sont très nombreuses
dans le secteur du bâtiment de la
crainte aussi exprimé à l'heure du débat
sur les travailleurs détachés par le
développement d'une économie à deux
vitesses
fondée sur le dumping social et la
précarisation de l'emploi
un débat de très bonne tenue où l'on a
regretté l'absence du candidat de la
république en marche